alors qu'on pouvait imaginer qu'avec
leur retraite au canada la presse people
se calmerait sur les rumeurs autour de
meghan markle et du prince harry en
début de semaine c'est le frère de
mégane qui a balancé qui se dit presque
sdf et qui prétend que c'est à cause de
mégane qui aurait selon lui tout fait
pour l'empêcher de décrocher un emploi
psychologiquement cela a été un
cauchemar depuis que megan s'est mise
avec harry elle aurait pu consacrer un
peu de son travail humanitaire pour nous
après le frère c'est le père de meghan
markle qui s'est exprimé il ya quelques
semaines thomass marque elle expliqué à
la presse à quel point la famille royale
étaient mauvaises c'est une des plus
grandes institutions monde
il a détruisent hilarante misérables et
enfin dernière nouvelle explosive
voilà maintenant que c'est la demi soeur
de mégane qui se met à balancer ce noël
meghan markle serait folle de jalousie
de kate middleton et pour mettre en
difficulté sa rivale l'ancien duchesse
de sussex n'aurait pas hésité à aller
jusqu'à cacher son anniversaire en effet
alors que kate s'apprêtait à profiter de
cette soirée magique mégane aurait fait
exprès de choisir ce soir là pour
annoncer leur souhait de quitter la
famille royale une manière de mettre les
projecteurs sur elle je pense qu'elle
est jalouse de la belle kate elle ne
pourra jamais rivaliser kite et iconique
toujours selon elle mégane est une
manipulatrice qui se serait servi de son
mariage et de la famille royale pour
briller il semble que la famille royale
britannique n'était qu'une rampe dans le
lancement vers les hautes sphères que
soute ne lui permettait d'attendre
alors selon vous la guerre est elle
déclarée entre qualité mégane la réponse
tout de suite
en plateau
[Applaudissements]
la cabale de la famille logan faut-il
croire à ces révélations vous a posé la
question également la guerre et elle
déclaré oui non il ya beaucoup de oui il
ya des noms et les gens qui sont de
mauvaise foi comme guillaume comme
d'habitude pas du tout commençait
pourtant la guerre est pas déclaré alors
que maintenant on sait que le père a
parlé le demi frère a parlé l'assesseur
à parler même dans sa famille personne
je vous expliquerai toute personne qui
les défendre c'est vous et un peu sa
mère encore même pas tellement pas du
tout pas du tout perdu alors jugé que
comment ça marche avec la famille
mérieux la famine arkle il ya donc la
mère de megan dont elle est très proche
et puis il ya son père avec qui elle est
brouillée et son demi frère et sa demi
soeur avec qui elle est totalement
brouillé oui comment ça marche et
pourquoi est ce qu'ils lisent ça fait
deux fois que les américains
oui fait des américains quand vous les
appelez moi je les fais je les appelais
j'ai dit voilà je rêve ou interviewer
aux caisses et 20000 dollars
et donc quand vous allez les appeler ils
vont pas vous dire évidemment parce que
ça n'intéresse personne
bon ben voila je la vois puis depuis des
années j'ai pas grand chose à vue désire
donc il va lancer fin parce qu'on les
paie pour balancer et donc les
journalistes adorent l'idée de balancer
sur sur meghan markle malgré six mois
pour de l'argent c'est balle en retrait
sur ta mère ton sur ta soeur non le fond
idée mais il se voit plus depuis des
années la mer inattendu mais lire j'ai
qu'elle dit quelquechose annuelle sensée
elle dit elle est jalouse de kate
parcelles ne sera jamais ne fera jamais
rien alors que tout mais c'est pas vrai
du tout alors que kate the stray cats
elle va très très bien qu'intel va être
un angleterre c'est ce nirvana des
traînes cathédrale pancake là on parle
justement de le guen elie qu'elle est on
aurait des jalouses de kate mais pas du
tout l est pas du tout jaloux ce si elle
avait été jalouse est ce elle serait
restée elle aurait fait la compétition
va pas faire la compétition alors
qu'elle a perdu d'avancé 13 ameren au
contraire ce que dit un petit mot pour
faire le buzz et piqué la lumière
accueil parce qu'elle voulait la lumière
d'une reine elle ne leur a jamais autres
nations la vraie information pied de 31
dès le 31 mars ça y est c'est officiel
ils ne seront plus membre de la famille
royale et il ya quelque chose qui se dit
c'est que mes buckingham ne l'a pas
encore officialisé la reine aurait
interdit qu'ils utilisent le nom royal
s'excuse chaque soir alors c'est pas
officielle catherine nom aussi pour
jeudi n'ont aussi parce que le problème
c'est pas la baguette alosi avec kate le
problème c'est qu'elle on voit qu'elle a
de mauvais rapports avec sa famille
elle et qu'elle a fait en sorte que
harry et des rapports compliqués mauvais
que sa famille alors qu'ils étaient
excellents jusqu'à présent donc c'est
une fille qui a des problèmes
relationnels très fort et je pense que
le pauvre harry là ça commence à devenir
compliqué pour lui se trouvait avec une
femme qui l'isolent équivaut jacques
labroue dit pas non à vous dit non alors
j'ai dit non qui se pose n'est pas kate
le problème c'est elle qui s'affaire
avec tout le monde
non la question rider mal formule est
confirmée c'est la merde pardon j'avais
à ma sauce voilà que sur kate
j'entendais dire dont d'accord et c'est
bien de jouer beaucoup d'impôts de bouma
catherine c'est vrai oui je pense
qu'effectivement le problème n'est pas
que sur requête mais le souci de megan
c'est qu'elle a l'impression que dès
qu'elle fait n'importe quoi elle mange
des petits pois un truc tout ça il ya le
monde entier qui est sur elle et qui va
dire à regarder qui va interpréter sur
interpréter chacun de ses gestes
pendant que sur kate personne ne dit
rien quoi qu'elle fasse froid que le
brame il est là elle en a marre d'avoir
toute l'attention en a marre pour pour
créer cette attention des médias sur
elle maintenant on se rend compte
qu'elle n'est pas seulement fâché avec
kate sait que toute la famille
d'angleterre ne veut plus en entendre
parler ils vont le supprimer son nom ils
les ont mis à l'écart et en plus ils
vont essayer de les empêcher de faire le
business ils ont envie de faire donc
elle s'est mis à l'écart mais elle a
surtout mis à rêver car et c'est là où
ça va poser problème à un moment je vais
près une question juste et je vous donne
la parole il reste encore du temps à
meriem est à vous mais c'est vrai que
pardon donc tu te dis moi leucémie sa
famille à dos elle s'est mise
kate et william à dos elle s'est mis les
anglais à dos et 6000 arena d'autre part
dont partout où elles passent ces
gens-là déteste c'est quand même un
petit truc et puis effectivement ça sera
de les deux infos intéressantes la
première c'est qu'elle serait jalouse de
calme et la deuxième c'est qu'elle
profite en fait de toute cette lumière
là pour devenir la star qu'elle n'a pas
pu être en vie dans la série sous ça
marchait pas et du coup même signé
derrière le dos de la reine et de la
monarchie des contrats avec disney et
encaissé du pognon pas là pour elle
c'est juste un coup de projets il
n'existe pas
c'est un mec amoureux de wever ne veut
pas dire qu'elle n'est pas jalouse de
kate et que tout va bien entre les deux
fin je vous rappelle juste que quand
même kate et william n'ont pas vu leurs
fleurs laurent leurs enfants quand il
est né tout de suite qu'elle ne se sont
pas parlé pendant des mois et que pour
annoncer qu'ils quittaient la famille
son royal ils ont ils ont choisi le jour
de l'anniversaire de kate un bâtiment
donc à un moment alors qu'elle était
censée fêter ça
c'est l'avocat de ma guillot c'est pas
possible de manger chaud comme ça merci
myriam qui a remis un petit à petit de
p3 la maîtrise au milieu du village est
un mets ta gueule les abeilles nommé il
ya un truc d'une violence énorme c'est
que harry a bien dit qu'il ne veut pas
que l'on fasse le même sort à une femme
qu'on l'attendait à sa mère ça c'est
fondamental parce que henry et avaries
harry est quand même assez content de
s'éloigner car il adore savoir allait
continuer à lui fasse le même sort
j'en europa qu'elles deviennent folles
avec les paparazzi bad justement il en
train de faire en sorte que ça va
arriver c'est justement exactement kate
et william la question s'est jamais posé
la question de lady di là il prend une
femme qui fait tout pour faire le buzz
la famille à dos les machins tout et
après des attentions et et il sait il
enlève la protection qu'ils avaient mais
en angleterre dans la famille royale
exactement les bons mais on est en
exercice ont fait un essai un chez vous
un essai 10 15 secondes et se met en
fête et on se base sur les déclarations
de sa soeur kate et elles se parlent pas
ils sont fâchés à mort donc en fait vous
croyez pas que la soeur et la balance un
scoop je vous dit c'est illogique moi je
suis totalement d'accord avec guillaume
histoire avec une dette de la part d'une
femme qui ne lui parle pas des bassins
les pros paul samantha sa soeur c'est la
merde cette fois qu'on parle de kits on
a des manques parce que la famille dit
que non
cet incident tribulations des
réputations de kate parce que c'est
peut-être de turin problèmes arrivent
tout seul brenda mais alors là on a eu
un avis maintenant on a des infos à
chaque fois qu'un cas membres de la
famille royale veut épouser quelqu'un il
y à une enquête sur sept personnes tous
les membres via une enquête
et là on se demande quand même comment
harry a pu poser cette femme qui déjà
été déboursés ce qui est pas un atout
pour entre la famille royale et il
aurait dû accueillir sa famille et à sa
famille de ses rapports mais je le
savais mais ça peut être ça a été ma
plus grosse erreur je pense que l'on
qu'elle enquête a été bâclée qu'ils ont
été trop vite et carrie a fait une
erreur et qu'on va le payer adrien par
un divorce les a souvent je suis bien
d'accord avec vous justement pour dire
que buts et mathieu on avait un scoop de
mathieu enfin kito times de michel
polnareff je sais qu'il nous regarde
beaucoup ça me touche beaucoup
on n'a pas la semaine prochaine mais
comme c'était un tout petit peu loin de
le contextualiser voulait pas qu'on
passe en 30 secondes
oui je n'en a pas si michel nous regarde
pas ce qu'on avait prévenu on le fait la
semaine prochaine
j'adore que je parle aux stars comme sa
vie et viseur on à sa soeur ici oui
pardon ce que megan est vraiment est
parti de la monarchie parce qu'elle
supportait pas le fait qu'elle soit
inférieure à kate parce que même dans le
protocole etc
elle était toujours un peu en retrait et
elle elle veut être devant devant la
scène en fait c'est une star elle
absolument parce que vraiment elle à
cette rivalité avec kate très bien et
juste a alors alors que ceux qui savent
donc là mathieu mathieu cela le 31
effectivement c'est le scoop asselah
elles vont avoir la sortie officielle à
londres d'ici le printemps a brassé
signifie ni et après c'est certain c'est
fini après ils seront officiellement en
dehors de la famille voilà ils vont
revenir à londres pour parler
d'événement et après leur vie s'attarder
conférence à 500 mille balles et ça va
un petit peu ce qu'on a vu oui mais je
voulais juste qu'on arrête de taper
taper sur megan parce qu'à mon sens le
problème c'est harry qui a un enfant
c'est tout non il est un homme amoureux
et quand on est mort on m'a donc c'est
quelqu'un d' immature qui ne contrôle
plus rien c'est un enfant c'est de façon
élégante de dire car il n'est pas très
intelligent mais arrêtez
c'est étudient la torah des séries non
majoré fuite mais voilà d'amoureux la
raison est remplacé par l'émotion cole
et loire il a mis ma g mais pas les lois
parents des poètes et de lire un petit
peu sa peau est dispo les lois c'est un
poète de crois vraiment pas du temps et
ses suites - si vous n'avez pas de
culture c'était votre problème et rions
adhérents vous n'êtes pas le jeune
allemand